am 6 august 1945 wurde über hiroshima
die erste und zwei tage darauf über
nagasaki die letzte atombombe mit
zivilisten als ziel abgeworfen
mehr als 100.000 menschen starben sofort
macht den beiden explosionen die
todesopfer der langzeitschäden reichen
je nach schätzung von vielen
hunderttausend bis zu mehreren millionen
was kann eine solche verwüstung
anrichten wie funktioniert eine
atombombe
die antwort gibt es jetzt bei kist um
science-fiction
der wichtigste teil einer atombombe ist
das spaltmaterial hierzu wird oft uran
oder plutonium verwendet das hat auch
einen bestimmten grund beide elemente
sind radioaktiv das bedeutet sie
zerfallen mit der zeit von alleine in
weitere elemente bei jedem dieser fälle
wird eine gewisse energie freigesetzt
bei uran sind das ungefähr 200 meter
elektronenvolt
das an sich ist sehr wenig allerdings
kann man sich die radioaktive
eigenschaft von diesem spaltmaterial
zunutze machen
gewisse in loope von uran und plutonium
besitzen mehr neutronen diese isotope
kann man auch als waffenfähiges uran bzw
plutonium bezeichnen denn wenn man
diesen isotopen ein weiteres neutronen
hinzufügt dann geschieht die spaltung
des elements sofort bei einer atombombe
wird sich außerdem zu nutze gemacht dass
ein zerfall die energie von 200 megawatt
ronan wollte in form von zwei weiteren
neutronen abgibt diese finden keinen
platz in den neu entstanden elementen
und werden weggeschossen das verheerende
an einer atombombe ist die kritische
masse wenn diese erreicht ist können die
beiden neutronen weitere uran oder
plutonium isotope erreichen und diese
wieder spalten
es wird eine riesige kettenreaktion
ausgelöst die sich immer weiter in die
höhe schaukelt das spaltmaterial einer
atombombe ist vor der zündung in unter
kritischen zustand hier und da zerfallen
mal ein paar uran atomen aber eine
kettenreaktion kann nicht ausgelöst
werden
da die einzelnen atome nicht dicht genug
beieinander sind um die kritische masse
zu erreichen wird in atombomben oft
herkömmlicher sprengstoff eingesetzt
dieser umgibt das uran bzw protonen wenn
die bombe jetzt gezündet wird dann
explodiert der sprengstoff um das
spaltmaterial herum
dazu wird zb tnt verwendet der druck
dieser explosion verzichtet die
spaltmaße so stark dass sie über
kritisch wird in einem sekundenbruchteil
läuft die kettenreaktion ab und eine
bombe von extremer sprengkraft
explodiert
die bombe von hiroshima little boy hatte
eine sprengkraft von 12.500 tonnen tnt
und tötete 80.000 menschen in einer
sekunde heutige spalt bomben erreichen
spreng kräfte von bis zu 300.000 tonnen
tnt das ist das 23 fache
dann gibt es allerdings noch
wasserstoffbomben diese funktionieren
ähnlich wie die gerade angesprochenen
spalt bomben nur dass die atome hier
fusioniert werden auch dabei wird
energie freigesetzt und auch hier wird
die überflüssige energie in form von
neutronen abgegeben die dann eine
kettenreaktion in gang setzen können
heutige wasserstoffbomben erreichen
spreng kräfte von bis zu 25 megatonnen
tnt
das entspricht dem 80 fachen der
stärksten spalt bomben und dem 2000
fachen der hiroshima-bombe mittel beugt
ich denke mal denn heutzutage ein
weltkrieg ausbrechen würde und sich die
großen mächten dieser welt mit den
heutigen atombombe werfen dann wird das
der letzte welt sein den die menschheit
jemals führen kann ist bestimmt schon
aufgefallen wo ich hier sitze ich bin am
set des youtube kanals der erste welt
auf dem ihr euch 100 jahre nach dem
ersten weltkrieg quasi in echtzeit alles
über den damaligen krieg erzählen gerade
läuft eine spannende miniserie zu den
waffen des ersten weltkriegs wenn euch
interessiert mit welchen gewähren die
soldaten vor 100 jahren gekämpft haben
und ihr auch sehen wollt wie wir damit
schießen dann klickt jetzt hier oben
um zu diesem video zu kommen zum weg zum
app und zum blog geht's wie immer da und
was meint ihr wird die menschheit jemals
eine stärkere und noch grausamere waffe
als die atombombe erfinden können
diskutiert es mit mir unten in den
kommentaren
bis dann bleibt dran